hey everyone and welcome back to the
channel for those of you of my viewers
who are American happy Fourth of July
weekend for those of you who are not
America is number one and uh yeah let's
learn about some systems design in the
American Spirit so I spent about three
hours preparing to make this video
because I couldn't remember for the life
of me why spanner was so special and uh
after a bit basically I finally did so
let's go ahead and talk about it
alrighty so spanner is a relational
database and the main problem that it's
going to help us solve is performing
distributed reads in a manner that is a
lot more efficient so let's go ahead and
give everyone some backgrounds so we can
all get up to speed here what is a
distributed read well in relational
databases we tend to partition our data
and frankly we even do that in certain
nosql databases but the general gist is
that there are you know relationships
between pieces of data that might be on
different partitions and as a result of
that we have to be able to basically
perform reads on both of those
partitions that keep those relationships
intact so for example let's say I wanted
to read all of these comments on both
partition a and partition B over here
and every single comment can also have a
parent and that's going to be shown by
this parent ID and so for example if I
were to read partition B I see that this
comment over here go next has a parent
comment with ID A1 where A1 is held on
partition a and that is the comment
Celtics suck so we need to be able to
make sure that we are maintaining our
causal relationship here when we perform
reads meaning that if I see this comment
right here B1 I better also see A1 or
else we're going to have a problem our
data is not going to make sense and
we're going to say what the hell is
happening
so again that's kind of the point of
this next little drawing here to Define
causal consistency in a more clear way
if we have two rights A and B and B
basically depends on right a and I have
a read from a database that contains
write B my read better also contain
write a or else my read is not causally
consistent so what's an example that is
not causally consistent
well it basically has these following
steps right here the first is that we
have a transaction one which is going to
see some comment comment one on
partition a
and then we also have partition B on the
right so the next thing that's going to
happen the second step is that we have
some transaction two which is going to
write a comment two and then in the
third step transaction three is going to
write comment three that responds to
comment two which means that 3 is
dependent
on two so there's a causal relationship
there and then finally in step four T1
is going to C comment three and it's
going to see hey this thing is dependent
on comment two and then it's going to
say well I never saw a comment two the
first time I read partition a over here
because it happened in between steps one
and step four in step two so we need to
make sure that when we do our read from
T1 and T1 is going to be reading from
here and also from here that we have a
causally consistent State between the
two of them
so can we solve this problem with
snapshots because you know you may be
thinking oh well if I take a snapshot
from one database and I take a snapshot
from the other database and they're kind
of you know the snapshots that
correspond with each other then we
should be good to go they'll be causally
consistent and yes technically that's
true however the question is how do we
know which snapshots they are because
these are different partitions the
transactions that interact on those
partitions are not ordered or maintained
in any similar grouping and as a result
of that we could have something like
transaction 101 and transaction 102 over
here and at the same time on partition B
you could have something like
transaction 25 so there's no like you
know kind of syncing of transaction
numbers that goes on between partitions
and if there were it would greatly slow
down the database so it's really hard
for us to get a sense of you know kind
of aligning these snapshots on different
databases in order to get a causally
consistent read and even if we could
eventually do that you know maybe I was
able to say oh you know snapshot 25
competition B happened at the same time
as snapshot 101 on partition a that
wouldn't even have all necessarily the
most up-to-date data it might be
causally consistent but we might still
be missing some rights that occurred in
the meantime such as write number 102
right there because we wouldn't need
that we would only say I want to read
from snapshot 101. so the point is that
would not be a sufficient solution for
this problem so what do we actually do
in practice in most SQL or relational
databases
well typically what we will do is use
locking so let me zoom in a little bit
here and so unlike before in our kind of
bad read where we did not maintain
causal consistency this time around if
you want to do a read of multiple notes
we're basically performing two-phase
locking right we're in two phase locking
readers grab
a shared lock
and so that's exactly what we're going
to do right here in Step One basically
we are going to grab the lock on all the
database rows that we're reading which
is going to basically be the entire
table because the point is we want to
read every single row on our table and
in this case that would use something
like a predicate lock in order to make
sure that no new rows can be written
and so we have our predicate lock on all
rows
and so now when transaction two comes
along and tries to write comment two it
is going to attempt to grab a row that
is already grabbed by the predicate lock
and it's going to fail and so now in
step three when T1 is going to read all
comments from partition B again it's
going to have to grab all the locks to
do so again via a predicate
and there is not going to be a fail
anymore we're going to see causally
consistent data what's the problem with
this well grabbing locks is freaking
slow not only is it slow to literally
grab blocks because that just takes
resources in terms of CPU Cycles but
it's also slow in the sense that it
prevents new rights
so if we're trying to read our entire
database right if we want to do
something like an analytical query and
we have to read our entire distributed
database we are locking literally every
single row on that database and now not
a single write can occur in the meantime
and so that is going to quite literally
stop our system from progressing every
single user is going to get pissed off
and you're going to hear a lot of
complaints so how does spanner address
this issue well spanner actually does
allow us to make causally consistent
reads from snapshots however as opposed
to using snapshots that are based off of
transaction number it actually uses them
based on timestamps so that means that
we don't have to perform any locking
because if I say you know here's a right
at 1 50 pm
get me all rights before them you know
get me all rights with the timestamps
that are less than that and that's going
to work actually so let's go ahead and
show you guys how that does
so let's imagine we've got two
partitions here partition one and
partition two and we're going to come
across some rights that have a causal
dependency
so what spanner will actually do is the
following it's going to receive a write
number one and it's going to say okay
we know that time stamps in distributed
systems are not perfect this is
something we've talked about a lot the
clocks can drift there's Network latency
all of this other stuff so what we're
going to do is assign it an uncertainty
interval where we're saying 99.999 sure
that the time stamp of the right is
within that value so in this case let's
say that value is 100 at 102. so we're
99 certain that that right came in
between time 100 and time 102. so that
time interval has a Delta of two seconds
right basically the width of the
interval is two seconds so what spanner
will actually do is it'll wait two
seconds and then commit the right and so
what that means is that the actual
timestamp that is assigned to the right
will absolutely be greater than 102
right because no matter what time the
right came in you know right comes in
between
uh 100 and 102 and any number between
100 and 102 plus 2 is going to be
greater than 102. so that's simple right
there so we know that actual time stamp
that this right is going to be assigned
is going to be greater than 102 so let's
go ahead and call that T1 for now now
let's imagine we had a second right on
partition two where the second right has
a causal dependency on the first right
so it's going to read it at some point
and then it's actually going to go ahead
and write to another partition well
first of all we know that if a second
right reads our first right it is going
to have to read it at time T1 or later
because of the fact that while that
right wouldn't have been committed
otherwise it wouldn't have been visible
so obviously it's going to be red only
after it's been committed so W2 is going
to read write one right to partition two
which again clearly happens after time
102.
so the uncertainty interval that's going
to be assigned to time W2 by a partition
two let's call it X comma Y what do we
know about X comma y well we know that Y
is obviously going to be greater than T1
this is very important we know that
since this right occurs in Real Life
After Time T1 that obviously the maximum
bound of the uncertainty interval is
going to be after T1 because it's got to
include T1 in it right hopefully that
makes sense if this write happens at
time 103 we certainly know that the
upper bound of the time interval is
going to be greater than T1 whatever T1
is so what are we going to do like
before our Delta is going to be y minus
X because that's the size of the
interval so we're going to wait y minus
X seconds and then we're going to commit
and so regardless of what this interval
is X comma y let's say we have T1 here
and now we have X comma y
and then you know who knows T2 could be
here or something once we wait x minus y
we know with 100 certainty that T2 is
going to be greater than T1 and so if
that's the case it means that any two
rights where there is a causal
dependency between them the one that is
dependent on the first right is going to
have a later time stamp than the first
right
and so because spanner established this
is invariant what it means is that we
can actually do things like this where
we say give me all rights with a
timestamp less than or equal to a
certain timestamp and we know that it's
going to be causally consistent which is
a super super useful principle however
at the same time you might be thinking
to yourself wait if all of our rights
have to weight the length of the time
interval Delta before we actually commit
them that is going to significantly slow
down the performance of our database
right well you would be right if Delta
was big if Delta is super super small if
we're very confident about the time
interval that each right is in then we
actually don't have to wait a lot of
time at all and it's not a big
performance hit so how can we be super
certain about the time interval that
every single one of our rights reaches a
database partition well what we could do
is what spanner does which is this right
here a GPS clock and so in every single
data center that spanner databases live
in we have an actual GPS clock which is
as synchronized as humanly possible to
the real time so that we can be as
accurate as possible in our timestamps
of course this doesn't remove all
uncertainty from our timestamps they're
still clock drift and there's still some
Network delay but at the same time by
making this Delta range as small as
humanly possible we go ahead and make
sure that each right is waiting a very
little amount of time so again for every
single Data Center
we have one of these clocks in there
what's the con of this well on one hand
even though when we have these kind of
clocks in every single data center we
can perform really really fast reads
without needing to lock it means that
these databases are a lot more expensive
spanner is not an open source database
it is something that you very much have
to get through Google Cloud because
you're using Google data centers and as
a result of that it is a lot more
expensive to operate one of these and
you know basically pay to have your
service running on them than it is to
just say you know take a MySQL instance
and throw it on AWS so with that in mind
even though these are super amazing
systems and super useful oftentimes for
some companies barring very very
specific and stringent performance
requirements it's not that practical
that being said I still of course find
it a cool video I think it's an
interesting topic and I definitely think
it is worth talking about hence why I've
wasted your 10 minutes of time doing so
anyways guys have a great weekend and I
will see you in the next one